three yes two one go hello welcome to a
double just play video games here on
PlayStation grenade I am Adam and as
always I'm joined by James how are you
sir
I just fell flat on my face in the snow
oh and I did it again today we are
playing a new game called steep it is in
open beta status so there will be a few
glitches along the way but we think it's
worth a try
so I'm hoping for again my SSS trick
from the first two days I think I don't
know the words
it's steep steep stood it still is deep
its deep it's really cheap it's not
cheap it's gonna be 55 great the
greatest thing I've noticed so far is if
you just jump in your wing so in the
wrong direction
you can snow angels this is the whole
game I'm happy
let's learn the basics let's do some
wingsuit jumping let's do it
jump can i bashes here not say well I'll
do a parachute so you can catch up on
the big yellow parachute in a balloon in
front of me it looks like what up in
Rumford sex oh I've died I've just
keeled over
I mean guys are the straw so what we
gonna do you've got to get as close to
the edge as you can without falling and
then you switch to your wingsuit and
it's who can go the farthest on the ice
okay yeah best investor dream
oh I'm gonna try again from here oh that
was excellent
I'll call it one on one our last or next
one wins skate celebrate I'll do a lap
on the ice celebrate right James this
challenge is called the Red Bull ultra
natural Aramis oh this this challenge
it's a way for centuries north for
millennium people have wondered what's
better skis or snowboards so it's time
to go back to mythical times when Sir
Lancelot would be a skier and Merlin
would prefer the snowboard
I shall represent Lancelot you Merlin
are you ready for this challenge Jimbo I
am ready and I'm very proud of my
snowboard let's do this go go go teams
game
so I put up to do anything odd crushed
you've got a chance now I need you do
something good oh come on yeah that
flips kalach here we go silver medal
running backwards what do I get
oh oh we can draw in the snow by walking
along are you just keeping with
testicles and I'm just gonna work on the
shaft that's pretty good
the elusive you losing the shepherd Adam
you gotta work the shaft
I've no advice I'll tell you what's more
entertaining than this game syphilis who
can go the farthest wins oh I think I
win that one I think I win that gun okay
okay we'll give you that one right now
we've run back to the top Oh close
orange in the lead blue caps you nope oh
I think I might overtake you here
oh yeah he's overtaken him it's their
new world record the champions my friend
go and I'm coming yes there we go it's
not my good oh no I'm stuck oh yes I am
just sliding down the mountain this is
so much better than any of the
intentional games thing that I'm really
not
about I thought we could jump between
the spots whenever your liked that would
make it a really compelling game but the
idea is good give them credit for that
anyway we will end this video as we
enter all our videos by committing
suicide from the highest object we've
got job
I can't wait to die after playing this
game it's not about bad it'll get better
this one Adam and Jen's play video games
here on PlayStation grenade if you've
enjoyed this video but please give us a
like and maybe subscribe as well
we'll be back each and every week with
more videos like this so one last thing
to say is goodbye sweet prince and I'm
dead and I'm dead apparently all I have
to do is tell the mountain what I want
and where I want to go and it will point
me in the right direction but mountain I
want to be off this game we should have
a new series called let's not play